devastating news for supporters who were
celebrating just yesterday that thrill
three-nil win over Stoke which of course
brings them up to 14th in the
championship and less than a month after
new owners took over the club and the
club itself have blamed the corona virus
pandemic for this happening it's said
that it's had a significant impact on
the football club's finances and we've
had a statement in from Gerard Kroszner
who is one of the administrators that's
taken over the club as of today to deal
with potential buyers and it he's
outlined that immediate objectives he
says are to ensure the club completes
all of its fixtures this season and to
urgently find interested parties to save
Wigan Athletic and the jobs of the
people who work for the club obviously
it goes on to say the suspension of the
championship season due to covert 19 has
had a significant impact on the recent
fortunes for the club he goes on to say
Wigan Athletic has been a focal point
and source of pride for the town since
1932
and anyone who is interested in buying
this historic sporting institution
should contact the joint administrators
directly now in the club's most recent
annual records it has had a net loss of
around nine point two million pounds and
that's leading up to June 2019 last year
and that's up 1.5 million pounds
compared to the year before so some
indication there that perhaps things
were going down south just listening to
the conversation online amongst sporting
experts there is some surprise that it's
a championship club that's been the
first to be hit by the corona virus
pandemic some suggestion that maybe
leagues one or league two clubs might
have been hit first particularly as
they're more likely to have a little bit
more money around so the hunt is on
though for Wigan Athletic to find a
buyer desperately for this club for a
club that has been around for 88 years